okay
hello everyone um thanks for coming
thanks for coming
um yeah like jared said i've actually
been coming to these meetups since like
2015 or so um jared's been trying to get
me to talk at one for a while
i spoke at the con the conferences are
less overwhelming because it's like
there are so many speakers so there's
less you're less hyper visible so i have
to leave this for about as long as i
could
and now i'm here um so today i'm talking
about time series analysis um with a
focus on anomaly detection and
forecasting
so just two different ways that we can
approach time series
so a little bit about me i am a proud
new yorker i grew up here um
i'm currently at codecademy i'm the head
of data science there um and before that
i was mostly at large non-tech companies
um jetblue and york sports clubs
before i decided to pivot to modern
tech sex got tired of
the 90 data cleaning
so yeah here's my twitter handle and
some hashtags if you want to follow
along
i'm also a member of our ladies which
if you're not aware is another really
great meetup
in new york
for women in data science but not
limited to just women
yeah so
there's a lot to go over today so by the
end of this talk um we're going to start
by learning how to assess the quality of
your time series data
just to kind of figure out what you can
and can't do with it
and then i i feel like i often spend
like 60 of my 60 of my time just being
kind of like paralyzed by my data before
i actually touch it um
and uh
yeah so forecasting seasonal trends um
managing holidays and special events in
your forecasts both of those with
facebook profit which is a really cool
package that i'll be demoing today
we'll be working with google trends data
which i think is always really fun to
work with
and then we'll be wrapping up with not
talking about anomalize which is another
great package for anomaly detection that
draws on twitter's anomaly detection
package and the forecast package
so yeah so part one the origin story so
um how i got roped into this jared sent
me a message and was like hey you should
do a talk on time series forecasting um
and this was back a couple months ago
for the dcr conference
and before this i worked at jetblue
plain data is really interesting
jared knew that i worked on some
forecasting he was like you should share
all that stuff
and i was just like
well
i
casting is complicated and i have a
complicated relationship with
forecasting um
also that's just a small shout out to
facebook for developing profit
but
why is it complicated um i think it's
less so like the methods um like about
achieving the methods are one thing but
i think the complexity is more around
like the quality of data that you have
and sort of like the unreasonable
expectations that people have for
forecasting given the lack of quality
data
so my alternative title for this talk is
forecasting with time series or what to
do when your company confuses data
science with fortune telling
i think people kind of think of data
science as like magic and it's like
we're going to give you some numbers and
you just
tell me what the future holds
and one of my favorite stories about
this is i spoke at a middle school
career day a few years ago about my job
as a data scientist
these really eager
sixth graders
um just
hopped on that and started asking like
peppering me with questions this was
back in like 2016 so they were like well
donald trump become president this
wasn't in january
well the warriors make playoffs and like
basically they can't their understanding
of my job is like i use data to tell the
future um
and i think that's kind of true for work
sometimes too like sometimes work can
feel a little bit like this um where
people come in with numbers and they're
like well i have this data and if i
extrapolate it out um you see a lot of
like linear regression where it's like
endless growth we will keep 10xing
things every year non-stop
and xkcv comic
and i think a lot of it stems from a
mismatch and like the expectation of
like when you become a data scientist
and the reality of the data you get to
work with um
so i think a lot of people have heard
a lot of us spend like 80 percent of our
time cleaning the data before we are
actually able to work on the analysis
and i think a lot of limitations come
from the quality of data we have too of
just like we would like to work with
data that's like clean and well
organized um
with like clear patterns that you can
actually like do something that's useful
with
in reality there's a lot of
inconsistency
and
unpredictability in the data the data is
massive this makes it really hard to
track like just one singular metric
and i kind of feel like a lot of the
time i'm just like putting out fires and
just trying to figure out what's wrong
with the data instead of actually
analyzing it
um so given all of these constraints um
i just want to talk through like what
does forecastable data look like like
what quality should we look for in our
time series data um in order to be like
okay
i think i have enough data
that's good enough so i can create a
forecast that's actually useful
so
i think seasonal trends holidays and
known events
this comes in place a lot for a lot of
like e-commerce
flights that was like a major thing
working at jetblue controlling for
holiday travel
i pulled florist
or google search volume for florist
since 2010 and you can see that it's
very much correlated with valentine's
day which i kind of knew tried to be
seasonal um
and
i actually didn't realize that mother
mother's day a lot of people have
mothers
or so that
um yeah so i think a lot of this
a lot of our job at jetblue was in
putting holidays like
christmas um the surrounding days like
if we knew christmas fell closer to a
weekend people are more likely to take
like long weekends um stuff like that
just sort of be
dealing with you can force forecast
things when you actually know what's
going on so it's a domain knowledge and
um
known recurring events
and i think the other thing is
historical data you want
a good amount of data with recurring
regular trends if you've only cycled
through that trend one one time you
can't really predict it it's harder to
predict it
so here is earnings
google search volume for
earnings peaks about four times a year
every quarter companies release their
earnings people want to know what's
going on
with their socks
i figured there are a lot of finance
people in here
someone shouldn't we forecast our time
series data um so i tried to think of
like
interesting case studies um tesla
is
could be a lot of companies you see that
quarterly peak tesla is interesting
because elon musk is
pretty erratic and
kind of
makes it
conflate or conflates or interrupts like
product launches and quarterly whatever
earning calls by
just tweeting random things
so it makes it really hard to predict
and speaking of unpredictability donald
trump
recently
or just for the past few years
has been kind of has been really erratic
and it's
his tweets or behavior is pretty hard to
predict um this is really hard to
forecast
i guess the only known is
unpredictability
um or
spending something more positive if you
only started collecting data recently or
um a recent change of events led to
something different like a product
launch or
a rising star in politics
you don't really have enough data to
forecast it's really hard to know
where this is gonna where this is gonna
go
and i think speaking of alexandria
ocasio-cortez it's it's basically leads
me to say growth is a double-edged sword
so growth is great working for a company
being able to get paid
being profitable
but hockey stick growth that all these
uh startup companies and bc want you to
achieve
it's great from a business perspective
from a data science and forecasting
perspective it's really hard
to figure out what's
what the future will hold when you're
launching
multiple features over the course of a
year
and basically growth just creates
uncertainty and time series forecasting
and when you have a forecast with
a range that looks like this it's not
really useful like it's not actionable
um
i i think like most executives if i gave
this to them and was kind of like there
is a 50 range in how you will perform
this year will be like okay
you're fired but
um
yeah so i i'm gonna start talking about
profits that what's the last chart um
and i'm not live coding live coding
always goes terribly so i'm to pretend
to live code
this will be a live code simulation
so what is profit so profit is
a forecasting package that was open
sourced by
facebook
and it's really great it draws from a
lot of really popular
packages like forecasts was the big one
before that
how many people in this room have used
profit
okay not that many how many people have
used forecasts
a lot more so the way i describe
forecast and i think the way that sean
taylor the creator has described it too
it's it's basically like forecast but
you remove a lot of knobs to make it a
little bit easier to use
so forecast can be really confusing for
a lot of beginners and even for someone
who's been doing forecasting for a long
time it has a lot of complexity isn't
always needed um
and profit kind of removes removes a lot
of the noise and just focuses
directly on mostly time series analysis
and specifically for
business forecasting
so facebook is one of those companies
that just has like billions of events
firing every day
so they have a lot of data and they try
to use forecasting to solve these
problems and to predict what's going to
happen new features stuff like that
so profit does really well with business
metrics um and that's kind of like the
key audience for it
so it does really well with seasonal
data
where you have like hourly data or
weekly data captured
with at least a few months of history so
kind of what i was saying before if you
have a good amount of historical data
and seasonality it does really well with
they call it human scale seasonalities
so day of week and time of year
um and important holidays so
they mentioned the super bowl i think
sean taylor is like related in football
so you put that in there but um that
that was like a thing that we had to do
at jetblue too actually like every time
they announced a superficial location
someone had to go and close up all the
flights to prevent them from selling out
immediately
so yeah like controlling for random
holidays that are lesser known or a big
part of time series analysis
and knowing the holidays are unique to
your business
are the things that are
kind of following the domain knowledge
part of data science
um
and where profit does well too is it it
does well with data where there's
missing values that kind of
um
i'll go into it later but it does well
smoothing over missing data and still
projecting out seasonality because it
assumes seasonality is like a strong
function of your trend
so how does profit worth i promise this
is like the only math here it's not
it looks more scary than it actually is
so profit
i think when we think of forecasting a
lot of people are used to people working
with like massive sprawling excel
spreadsheets with like multiple tabs and
like multiple department heads putting
in their own version of what they want
to happen um
and it's really complex or you have
forecast which is also a pretty
complex i would say requires a good
level of knowledge to work with profit
reduces a lot of this and the only input
is time um so you're just working with
time time series data that's it your
only input is time so you're putting in
time and your observation and you're
measuring that um
and profit does really well with working
with seasonality like i mentioned um and
the
model basically assumes
that there is a general growth trend so
is it trending upwards or downwards over
overall over the years um seasonalities
or whether it's weekly monthly hourly
and holidays and this is a user input
that's um we talked about before with
like super bowl
calendar
holidays or so on
um so
i mentioned i like to work with google
trends data so
to start for this part and for
anomaly detection
we're mostly working with google trends
data google trends r is a really good
package to play with
i think it's just really fun to look at
like spikes and what people are
searching for
so once you have your data frame
profit
makes it pretty easy you kind of have to
do some prep work but it's pretty
it's pretty um
it's not a lot of prep work
so you need
a
uh
you need a date
so the
so profit one of my nitpicks of like
profit is it it forces you to
name your columns d s and y d s being
your date and y being your observation
um so this is just prepping the data
cleaning it for
analysis
um
and then google trends data so
um
are people familiar with how google
trends works
so it kind of normalizes search volume
over time so it's a minimum of zero and
a maximum of 100. so knowing that
and doing a logistic regression
i specify the floor as zero and the cap
as a hundred
this might vary um
for flights for example when we're
on jetblue every every flight had a
maximum number of seats so there are
only so many seats you can sell
and then you make future you make your
data frame for the future again you
specify the cap and the floor
and you create your forecast
and this is i generally don't look at it
but the output is kind of like
easily exportable um
into like a spreadsheet it's a data
frame um
everything is
uh you have a
midpoint
and
i did not rename these correctly
but you have a midpoint and lower and
upper ranges
and when you plot your forecast it looks
something like this so this goes back to
the google search volume for earnings so
it's able to predict the quarterly the
quarterly spikes
and people looking for earning calls or
information about company earnings
and you can actually break out the
components of your forecast and look at
the trend over time so that top graph
over there shows us that
google search volume for earnings has
been trending up since
2016 um and it shows you the four spikes
a year
um oh
yeah so if you look at the
if you look at the forecast for the
forecast output it's able to
predict
um the increase
in google search volume starting around
the end of april when most companies
close up their
q1 earnings
um
and this is
for
i call it simple but now that i'm going
over it and like profit is complicated
but
or it's hard to go over in an hour
there's a lot there's a lot of
documentation online though i encourage
you to go look at it um
but this is where the human input comes
into play of inputting relevant holidays
um and examples of this would be
not just calen not just like bank
holidays but um company earnings calls
product releases all the known
information that
you have about the data that you're
analyzing
um and that's the
data science venn diagram that
inevitably pops up but this is where the
substantive
expertise comes into play of just
knowing about your what you're analyzing
and the subject matter
so best practices for forecasting
set clear expectations i think when
you're
i had to learn how to do this but this
is basically just like being realistic
and honest about the data that you have
and what level of certainty you can
provide so if you have if you just
launched a new product or let's say
someone comes to you and it's like can
you forecast this i just launched a
product six months ago
feel free to be realistic and be like no
um
yeah i think just setting clear
expectations is important um
it takes a while for people to learn
what can and can't be forecasted um
i think
the second point to the second point
sharing upper and lower ranges also
allows people to be more realistic about
what they can expect
when you share just the midpoint
and i think
this has still
uh
i'm still trying to figure out how to
coach
people who work with forecast numbers to
do this
don't just use the midpoint use the
upper and lower ranges if you have a
really wide range in your data that
tells you that
your forecast might be brittle and not
hold up
updating your priors so i talked about
specifying the capacity and floor um
that might change as your business
changes so make sure you go back and
change those
i like to do it at least it depends on
the type of forecast but i try to
look back on on forecasts like about
quarterly for our um
for our
like new sign ups forecast for example
um holidays and launches
um there are certain so profit does as
well with um like it knows
when you're projecting something out
monthly it'll know that um thanksgiving
for example falls towards the end of the
of november but it won't know that
it changes every day so if you want it
to be more specific
and accurate within the week you have to
go back and update your holidays
same with product launches when you're
actually doing this in production
and
i'm going to skip ahead to the last
point but user spreadsheet people so i
think a lot of data scientists will
especially like out of school come in
really optimistic about the math and
kind of discount the internal knowledge
that a lot of people have at the company
um
and this knowledge is really valuable
like i've learned so much from people
who've been at companies for like 10 20
years who maybe aren't data scientists
and aren't very numbers oriented but
just know a lot about the product and
the business
and this has been like really critical
for developing useful forecasts
um
and going back up i think in
i'm still trying to figure out how to
work profit fully into our business
i think something where it's come in in
handy is i realize those sprawling
spreadsheets won't ever really go away
and where it's come in handy is having
people take my take of forecasts and
telling them well this is the reason
reasonable range you can expect unless
anything changes and having people
at the executive level determining well
if we are able to convert
or increase seo like how can this change
um our target so targets are like
wishful thinking
forecasts are what you can expect to
um to happen given the current
constraints
okay so going into the last part anomaly
detection just as a side note too
i'm like halfway through today i was
like i
went way too ambitious with this talk
this was too many topics
but hopefully you come away with a
little bit of everything and go home and
explore more just because there's so
much that can't be covered today
but both of these are really cool
packages
so for anomaly detection
i kept talking major at that time about
forecasting and i was like hey jared i'm
really disillusioned about forecasting
but i'm really excited about anomaly
detection because i just had like
um was able to implement that at work
and was really excited um and anomaly
detection has been really critical i
think for providing people
um
providing people something useful so
you're not just saying no all the time i
feel like i talk to people
to data scientists on my team a lot
about having to say no to people of like
no sorry like we can't provide that data
or no we haven't been collecting that
um
and it just
you feel like the bad guy a lot of the
time
so i think where anomaly detection has
been useful is you're able to provide
something that's often more actionable
than a brittle forecast or
something like that
and it's helped reduce the number of
fire drills
so fire drills
so going back to
to uh
anomaly detection it's really come in
handy for reducing
all of this
um
i feel like
this this probably is true for a lot of
people at work but just a lot of the
time something comes up at work and i
feel like i'm putting out fires more
often than i'm actually doing analysis
so i joke that my typical workflows i
start working on something i'm excited
about
and then suddenly someone like runs over
to me is like oh no like something is
broken i don't know what please help me
um and the thing that i was working on
just kind of like
falls away and
i just think longingly to
working on something more interesting
than putting out fires
so anomaly detection or how to know when
something is terribly wrong
or put out fires ahead of time
so some applications of anomaly
detection fraud detection
monitoring kpis
i found it really useful what i did at
work was i basically set up anomaly
detection for key checkouts
checkout flows on the website
so when something like that breaks
which is
what happened here
we're able to detect it earlier instead
of letting it go on for longer than
necessary
um
nature
weather
there are a lot of different
applications of anomaly detection
so i'll be talking about anomalize today
which is a really cool package to help
you go from
this scary
really sad graph
to this
where you can
instantly identify
and interpret like when something
potentially broke or changed
so anomalous
again we will be working with google
trends data
um
anomalize plays really well with the
tidy verse um so i don't are most how
many people here
are familiar with the tidy verse when i
when i say that
okay so most of you but the tidy verse
is a concept of programming where you
just
to put it simply it's like cleaner code
um it's changed my life
my my code is so much cleaner now it
looks almost like a real programming
language
and it's really easy also for
non-programmers to read which i love
and anomalize this setup in a way that
kind of uses this framework of thinking
to understand so your code looks really
nice
it does it plays well with like other
packages within the tidy burst
okay
nope
yeah
oh yeah that's it i forgot yeah
anomalize is really easy to use there's
so little code
so you basically yeah you install your
you can select inverse and anomalize you
prepare your data
um
and then you anomalize and this looks
like a lot of code but again please go
home and play with it there's a lot to
play around with
and i'll talk more about the methods
here in a bit so anomalize helps you
take your data to this so if i'm looking
at google search volume for vote
this was really fun to interpret but um
i actually did this for the dcr
conference back in november um shortly
after the midterms and the midterms
actually like outranked a lot of
previous presidential elections because
people were so excited
about
making things less depressing
but if you look at the
outliers you have the 2016 presidential
election
the 2018 recent midterms which were a
big deal
and then all the other presidential
elections and some sort of
and some smaller scale anomalies
of
probably local elections or surrounding
dates
um
florida i feel like proxy keywords are
really fun um florida the swingiest
swing state so i think just because i
was i was going down the voting trend
it was fun to look at how
floor or search searches for florida
peak like every presidential election
because people are like what will they
do now
and in the recent midterms there it was
in in the midterms it was particularly
contentious i feel like all
um elections there are like within one
percent um so there was really high
search volume for that
um and
yeah similar to
to um to profit there are a lot of like
really cool functions within a
normalized that let you look at like the
inner workings of um
anomaly detection and i think this is
nice because when we when we talk about
packages like anomalize and profit
i think
interpretability is really important as
a data scientist
providing things that are easy to
understand
especially when you work with
stakeholders who might not be as
tactical
people are really scared with what they
can't see
and when they can see what's going on
people tend to be more accepting of
of math
but
so this is kind of like a cheat sheet of
what i've learned
about anomaly detection so num um
anomalize actually draws from two
different existing packages anomaly
detection was um
anomaly detection one word um was a
package that was open sourced by twitter
which deals with
a lot of
a lot of event data a lot of outliers
the
eccentricies that i showed you with elon
musk and donald trump um
and twitter so twitter's open source
their anomaly detection algorithm that's
really great for dealing with like
highly seasonal data but also
teasing out outliers
iqr
is better in senator louis is better if
seasonality isn't a major factor
so kind of if you're looking at shorter
term data and you're not looking at
long-term trends um i usually defer to
standard lows but
it's easy anomalies makes it easy to
kind of like play around with with all
the different
algorithms to see what works with your
data
oftentimes i go in with like assumptions
about what i think will be true and i
end up being proven wrong
and adjust the trend period so
over here the trend period of the year
address the trend period using domain
knowledge
so this is just kind of what it looks
like in action
movers people look for movers about like
every month people move all the time
running it on standard louis from data
since 2015
once you do it with twitter it removes a
lot of the anomalies and pulls in
your median and then once you add in gsd
it pulls it in some more so if you look
at the gray range um
yeah it's it's cool
so try some different keywords um
i i had some fun just playing around
with this um this was from november i
don't know if it's still fair game to
make fun of pete davidson
and do it anyway um so pete davidson for
those of you who don't know
um
got engaged to ariana grande
um shortly after
they met so i think they met like
there
and then people were like who is this
guy
um and then a couple weeks later they
got engaged
the internet went crazy um the thing
that i find interesting too is you can
see the tab like how cyclical tabloids
are of like this
trend here
um
but there are outliers that break away
from that trend like shortly after when
they called off their engagement
and
search volume went up again
so try this at home i
i just kind of try to think of like
things that would be funny to look at
but i pointed out or elon musk is always
funny i don't actually follow him that
much so it's hard for me i just know
he's like kind of erratic um
but
sports weather politicians
bitcoin i feel like is also super
erratic
memes events anything timely
and anything else you might think of i
feel like at the end of the day when
you're a data scientist just work with
data that's interesting to you
that's probably going to get you to
learn the most
for me it was pete davidson apparently
so additional resources
i'm going to put this up
over the weekend
and
linking to
a lot of extensive documentation about
these two packages
um
there's so much i couldn't cover um both
of them are really great i also linked
to the not so standard deviations
podcast have people
listen to that um it's a really funny
podcast it feels like you have like two
data science friends in the room with
you
um so when you're working in silos on
your two-person data science team you
feel less lonely
and
they have one with sean taylor the
creator of profit where he kind of talks
through
profit and why he developed it and the
intended audience and kind of like his
learning so it's a really good episode
for just learning about open source
development but also like forecasting
and what that looks like at a business
and codecademy i relearn our uh
i've been speaking at conferences for a
while now for codecademy and every time
i have to be like we don't teach r um
but lerner is finally coming so that's
really exciting um i
i did not i did not teach it but there
are people
um
i'm just going to shout her out but
natalia is a curriculum developer she's
really awesome
and yeah it's it's going to be great
um and march meet up so
i went through this faster than i
thought um so march meetup um jared
mentioned it will be on choosing a deep
learning library um i took the liberty
of helping the march speaker pull
interest in deep learning um it's at
like
peak hype right now so if you want to be
at dinner parties and like
sound like you know what you're talking
about go to this talk
if you've also seen things like that
where
there's a picture and like some service
is able to detect what clothes you're
wearing and you're like why is this
service analyzing
my photo you can go find out how that
works
um
in the spirit of
full disclosure and also valentine's day
um chelsea is my statistically
significant other
i feel like i have to disclose that but
also geeky valentine's day
jokes a good meme
so that's it um
i finally have time for questions i feel
like i actually
gave a talk like this before
and had no time for questions and there
was so much content
i felt really bad like i was just
abandoning all these people and just
dumping information on them so if you
have questions um feel free to ask me
uh
oh yeah i guess as a last note too just
put a note here about supporting each
other um
i've just i've been coming to like
this meet up for a really long time and
i think just having this community has
helped me grow so much as a data
scientist
um and i probably would have abandoned
data science a lot earlier if i didn't
have it
so support each other
good luck have fun
play around with data like pete davidson
or
whatever is interesting to you
data science seems really or seemed
really used to seem really scary
and sometimes still is like an hour
before this talk i was like everything's
trash i can't do this
um
but yeah i don't know having looking
around i'm just like i know so many
people in here and that's wild like
i came into this room like a few years
ago and was like i have no idea what's
going on i don't know anyone and now i'm
like
i still sometimes don't know what's
going on but that's okay because i'm
eating pizza with my friends
so yeah
just appreciate this community take
advantage of it there's so much
that jared does to support the data
science community in new york
so yeah with that questions
i'll microphone so i'm gonna ask you to
shout your question and i want you to
repeat it for the people on camera it's
like a community forum
sure
uh
um so the question was i talked about um
let me try to flip back to it
flipping through all the memes
and
oh flip past it
i think i just i also just went way
faster
than i needed to because i i i'm always
afraid of running out of time um so
sorry if i
i didn't um take more time have more
time to spend on this um but basically
on a high level
anomalies just supports twitter and seo
stanford standard lewis um
am i pronouncing that right
it is right
the self-doubt creeps in but um so the
two i twitter tends to work really well
with very seasonal data twitter has if
you think about
twitter's um
twitter's business they just have a lot
of seasonality built in of like people
tend to tweet at certain hours of the
day
certain holidays events
so twitter deals well with seasonality
and helps control for it standard louis
is
kind of fine for
the other ninety percent of the time
um
gsd and iqr are
if you go back here um those are the two
methods for
um dealing with what we call the
remainder so once the
seasonality is controlled for you're
left for with outliers
and you have to choose a method to
figure out how to deal with them and
determine which one is an outlier and
which one isn't
i can't remember the exact math of it
off the top of my head
there's a lot of documentation online
though and the two gsc and iqr are just
different ways of
determining whether something is truly
an outlier or not
sure um
my question is about assumptions
so
how do you think about
let's say
assumptions on getting the business
stakeholders inputs into the assumptions
imagine as a scenario in the airline
industry jet fuel presence
how would you think about that
yeah so the package oh okay i keep
forgetting so the question was about
assumptions um and how
you incorporate assumptions into your
model from people who are not directly
working on the model so business
stakeholders leadership
um
yeah i think the thing to bring i feel
like every time i talk at something data
science people ask about assumptions
as if data scientists are
immune to making assumptions too
so i think that's the way to
approach it
it's really hard to incorporate feedback
from everyone
but i i think when it comes to
assumptions with profit it's less
it comes up mostly with holidays but i
think it's just like
trying to be
as collaborative
as possible while still getting your job
done is kind of my approach
so spending time collecting
collecting people's like advice people
who've been at the company and have
domain knowledge far longer
far more than i do
and trying to incorporate as much of
that as possible into the model
but kind of cutting it after a certain
point because
it just you go down a rabbit hole of
i feel like there's also the other thing
that i fall
um
i fall like i'm immune to or the trap of
like feeling paralyzed by your
assumptions where it's like oh no if if
i made all these assumptions and this my
analysis kind of hinges on this one
assumption and once i take it out
everything falls apart um
trying to move past that is kind of hard
too
i'm kind of like this is i have strong
opinions on this i feel like i could do
a whole talk on like data scientists and
assumptions but i think it's just like
the the best you can do is just make
everything really clear try to
communicate what assumptions you had um
if a lot of your model is based on this
one assumption about um like an increase
in fuel like you mentioned for airlines
you should make that clear when you
communicate out your forecast um
yeah
i have actually two questions the first
question how how you deal with missing
data let's say you have a process that
creates data and then and then the
process is broken there is no data and
then
and finally the process starts working
and you have a bunch of bunch of data
right so now your model will be broken
because there is no data now there is
spy
so how you would deal with that
situation and the second situation what
do you do if you have multi-sessionality
in your data
if you have multiple multiple
yeah
okay so question is how you deal
how to deal with missing data
um and multiple seasonality
yeah um so i think when it comes to
missing data that's where the domain
knowledge comes into play
it's really hard to apply like a one
size fits all solution
but i think it's just like assessing how
much damage
there is
there's like a wide range in in missing
data i've seen
um
i've seen like if you have like one day
missing profit is pretty good at
controlling for that um
but if there are
our profit is actually pretty good of
dealing with seasonality so i would
actually give that a shot if that works
for you specifically um
because it basically just tries to look
for the trend and seasonality over time
um can you elaborate on what you mean by
multi-seasonality
so let's say you you are looking in your
like
data right and you have like um days and
there is
they can be like for example like month
a month
for example january we have like
let's say on
so this is
i see so this is dealing with different
types of seasonality as in daily weekly
monthly um
i i just i duplicate my forecast a lot
and i will produce it for like a daily
forecast a weekly forecast a monthly
forecast and allow people to use
whatever is useful for them
um
that that kind of
there's because if you think about it
there's a wider range
of
of uh
i'm forgetting the word but your upper
and lower ratios can be much wider for a
monthly forecast versus like a daily
forecast
so generally just duplicating the
forecast for different
for different periods of time
can help with that
sorry the forecast package allows you to
put an indicator variable yeah
yeah
yeah you don't have to reshape your data
the package makes it so that you can you
can specify and just easily duplicate
your forecast for daily weekly monthly
whatever works for you
i use a sql and worker scheduling to do
a lot of learning and i want to move
towards something like anomalize but i
don't know what i would use to schedule
it or
format the results instead of
stakeholders do you
have any suggestions for those yeah
um so
someone asked a question they use
primarily sql and looker which is a bi
tool um
and that helps schedule a lot of the
analysis so the question is how can they
schedule something like anomaly
detection
um
so
i think our uh just learning how to
program you can schedule a lot of those
tasks to run
i actually one of the ways that i've
been trying to use
the forecast is piping it into if you
work with redshift or whatever data
warehouse you have
piping your forecast into the data
warehouse so you can
pull it into looker has been really
useful um
so there are ways but it does require
learning like a little bit of our python
or your preferred programming language
but you can schedule a lot of the same
tasks you can also do
um so you can yeah
there are various ways of doing it it it
depends but yes
yeah i haven't used that they let you
generate markdown reports which you can
mail out on the schedule with the
interactive graphics and
circle our studio
oh the other yeah i've actually found um
just a tip for people to
have people use mode
it's like a bi tool i know there's one
one mode user too or yeah mode is like a
bi tool that has a free version and it
actually lets you run and schedule
python and arm notebooks and connect it
directly to your data warehouse um or
there are free and paid versions and i
forget what the pricing looks like
but that that's really useful too
because it it allows you to kind of set
up an environment for analysis without
having to talk to like a data
engineering about spinning up a cluster
every time you want to do something
any more questions
yeah
so we when we talked about holidays in
the uh season in the first part of the
presentation he said you could put in
sort of regular traditional holidays and
also
anything that's a
one-day event
right so yeah like private launches or
conferences or something like that
does it have the ability to go back and
say
in the past that had holiday that had
product
launches had conferences
i have another conference coming up next
week or next month you can
update the way it will uh predict what
will happen
based off of the fact that coming up is
a conference and not
yeah so you can specify um so i can talk
about this i was worried i wouldn't have
enough time so i i didn't go into this
too much um but the way the holidays
work is it's
it's a manual input
so here i have an example of like
two different types of holidays so
holiday posts is holidays where the day
after the holiday tends to be
tends to have an impact on your metric
holiday pre is like
you can see the lower window and upper
window
and that can be
more than one or two it can be however
many days or weeks whatever time period
you know so if the conference goes on
for like two days or something you can
put plus two
um
and then it binds the different types of
holidays together um so i like to
separate out the different holidays
based on
how long of a period or what window of
time and in which direction
and then bind them together into
holidays
here
um
for the analysis
i guess my question is nuts
you might have like holidays which are
both like posts but some of them are
like christmas or yeah but some of them
are conferencing so christmas might
decrease the amount of traffic you have
but conferences might increase the
amount of traffic you have yeah so you
would try to group them together
um based on
be able to be likeness
so you know what to hold them here
well i'm wondering if they're the one
there's certain types of events that
occur even if they're not regular
yeah so you would put that so for
example if it was a product launch you
would just have a product launch data
frame and then put the dates for those
even with the lower window and upper
wood that would be the same as the other
ones it would know it's a different typo
yeah
so for each for each of these it's
specifying the data frame so if you have
a product launch for example that would
um change your
your trend for like a full week you
would put in um you put that in like
product launch
one week or something yeah and then just
put change the lower upper or change the
upper window i guess to seven
yes
so does it treat
so if you classify the holiday pose
yeah and then it incorporates um when we
talked about the growth trend it
incorporates a trend over time so let's
say 2018 is far stronger than 2017 it'll
try to adjust for making christmas in
2018 stronger than
christmas in 2017. if that makes sense
yeah
oh yeah also just to i actually didn't
sorry just um
to talk about how well forecast is there
are weeks where it's able to forecast
how many um signups we get on our our
website within like zero percent like
0.005
it's crazy and it's really simple so
um
it's really simple once you kind of like
cycle through it a few times so
i would encourage you test it out with
whatever metric you work on because
yeah the first time i used it i was just
like how can something
so simple be so effective
but yeah profit does really well with
with time series data
is it sorry
yeah it's um yeah i'm i'm not a python
user so i did it this with the lens on r
but python is a bit our
profit is available in python and r so
pick your poison how
you can tune many
the model like what's the input
like you have some input three years of
data you want to produce
you'll be giving this input just the
time series right you have extra wire
right
yeah so um the question is what are the
inputs um so
the inputs are you put in your time for
logistic regression so you can specif
you can do linear too it was just for
this example with google trends data
this was logistic um when you do
logistic you need the cap and the floor
um and you specify the so this this kind
of goes back to your question about
different periods um you specify the
frequency so here i'm making a um
i'm predicting the future out 52 weeks
so a full year out
and different parameters i didn't get to
touch upon this but
um
in addition to holidays you can also put
in change points so if you know for
example um this is where product
launches are it's useful for product
launches or some sort of significant
change too um or like the election
outcomes or something like that you can
put specify the change so
um
profit tries to manually detect the
change point so sort of like an
inflection point in your data but you
can manually override that and put it
put or and change it depending on
if if you think you know better than
um profit is able to change
how it works
decompose the time series
part plus the seasonality make
prediction of the trend and then the
applies reconciles the prediction
business
can you
so basically you come to times here
right yeah
how does it work
right yeah so the output um there's a
lot more in the forecast so i only
pulled the just for readability i only
wait actually maybe i can show you
uh
so the forecast
um
the actual the forecast itself the
output has a lot in there
for
for the purpose of of this
talk i only looked at the upper and
lower ranges but you can kind of look
through
um how it interprets the yearly trend um
and
this kind of lets you look under the
hood if that makes sense um
there's yeah there's the the thing with
profit is it can be simple but it can
also be really complicated so it
it depends on how deep you want to go
into interpreting your forecast
any other questions yes
do you have a good way to
quantify seasonality just if you're
choosing between
like the twitter algorithm which is what
i've used in the past but then i haven't
used the other one that you mentioned so
i'm trying to decide you know which of
those should i use and also
could you have it have that happen
automatically if you were
using anomalize and trying to
just have
okay i thought you said like time was up
um the question is uh
no i'm forgetting the question is
quantifying seasonality and choosing
between um
whether you should use twitter um the
twitter method or not um
good question i i don't know how you
quantify exactly i think it's more like
looking for characteristics of your data
um twitter tends to do well with like
longer term seasonality um
and like for example the pete davidson
for example i just use standard lois
instead of twitter because there's
there's no
yeah yeah so twitter uses stl but it
also has um
it also has gest is also part of it so
those are two separate things
um
wait no now i'm like sorry i so the
question was
other than looking at your data yeah is
there some way to quantify it so that
you could pass that to your function and
it would choose the right one
like choose the right one for you
like so okay so the question is whether
you can kind of like
um quantify
the what seasonality is so that you
so that the process of selecting the
method is automated um good question
uh
let me look at the
so i think
there is a way so i think that the good
thing about about this being done in
tidy versus
you could
i guess you could write a function to do
it
and wrap it within that um i haven't
tried it so i i don't i don't want to be
like here's how you would do it but it
is possible um
you yeah always reduce errors so you can
just like combine them to like take like
a bunch of methods and just like take
average
and just like i'll do like something
yeah usually like bunch of metals they
work really well
on average
yeah i mean it it makes it because it's
it's like um a tidy verse package or
follows that it makes it really easy to
to try to do that or to
wrap it within a function
um so i would suggest trying that
i haven't tried it myself but now i'm
like i should do it yeah
um
good idea thank you
um have you ever would you ever use
profit
not necessarily to forecast but to kind
of say oh i want to look at the
seasonality of this and you know ignore
the overall trends just to
um i haven't used it specifically for
seasonality analysis like what type of
seasonality analysis are you thinking of
oh the question was whether you would
ever use profit just for a seasonality
analysis right if you wanted to kind of
know
you know either weekly or
season or annual trends yeah but you
wanted to like separate out
the general trends you just wanted to
know what parts of the year are better
yeah it does allow you to do that um
the part that i showed with the forecast
components um so this i pulled weekly
google search data but if you have daily
data it's able to tease out the um
is able to tease out like the day of
week trends too like if mondays are
stronger
saturdays are weaker i wanted to have
like charts and be like oh so now i know
i should always deploy something on
mondays because mondays are the best
yeah
yeah i think for like business use cases
it's good for like um demand planning
servers stuff like that um or
when it when you think about like uh
like marketing and the product side of
things like we
have used seasonality to help decide
when to run like sales or promotions or
if we know back to school season is
really big for codecademy
so we really want to be able to
anticipate that and capitalize on it
any more questions let's do two more
myths okay two more maps
second and last questions
how do you do with the steps like using
like cross-validation you separate your
data and feel like five years of data
using the first four years to train it
and then look at the
accuracy on the last year like what is
the standard way of doing that yeah so
i've done that before where i've just
pulled um
i pulled the data like up or the full
data for the actuals
but trained it using like
removing the last few months or last
year
it's more like testing i think it means
like testing your model
yeah
in particular but
i think like with all the parameters
like between the hyper parameters what's
the right best way to do that they use a
ac and they see as a method inside the
strategies they always use this for you
they only keep their best model by
everything
but after you specify that
they pick like all these packages they
pick the best models for you based on ac
so there is something built all right
yeah
i think if it if you're doing it man
or
for what you can't control i think um
it's just kind of best practice to know
before like profit work really well for
us but it might not work well for your
data so um in order to test whether
profit is good for you i would suggest
like
um
slicing some of your data and seeing how
accurate it is
forecast and our sample have
time series cross validation you can use
yeah the forecast package has tscv and
and max has written a
whole blog post at the whole article
about how to use our sample for doing
crosshair time series cross validation
they're both available for you
yeah
yeah forecast is a lot more robust if
you want to just um
have more more knobs to play with yeah
last question um
sorry yeah last question um
pressure a little bit but um
yeah so uh when you are adding holidays
is there an easy way to make some
holidays like more powerful than others
say you're working with education data
across the country and some schools use
some holidays and some schools don't
yeah
yeah um generally so because seasonality
is such a big component of profit
if it's a holiday it occurs around the
same time of year it won't it won't um
it won't put one holiday at the same
magnitude of all other holidays if that
makes sense
does that answer your question
the other way of doing that is also
separate you can separate it out and use
the the upper and lower windows again
um but it's pretty good at
um
i think i found that it so when when
working with holidays i think it does
pretty well with like weekly forecasts
and monthly forecasts for example um but
daily forecasts it's it's not always
great just because it's
um daily forecasters it's just hard to
forecast daily
and i think that was the last question
but thank you all for coming